there are two different api's for this
device orientation and device motion
both of which are really interesting
device orientation tells you which way
the device is tilted and which way it's
pointed this can be useful for
implementing a virtual joystick for
example or implementing a compass device
motion gives you events and information
about what forces are being applied to
the device which makes it easy to tell
if you're shaking the device but it also
lets you include and exclude gravity
this means it can tell you how the
device is oriented to it's really a
strict superset of device orientation
but it's a bit more challenging to use
in that way so given these descriptions
and which of these scenarios do you
think you would use device orientation
and in which would you use device motion